let's talk about black seed it's quite
interesting it's been around for a very
long time in many cultures they actually
found these black seeds present
in the ancient egyptian tomb
of the pharaoh tudoka moon which is king
tut so the properties of this oil in
black seed
is quite extensive so let's go to the
list
asthma hypertension diabetes pain
inflammation antimicrobial
anti-fungal
antiviral
antibacterial
number seven anti-cancer the
anti-phytonutrient called
thymoquinone it actually causes the
cancer to commit suicide
without creating any problem on normal
cells it's called apoptosis there's a
study which i'll list below apparently
black seed is a significant inhibitor of
solid tumors
in
mice now the other mechanism of how it
deals with cancer which is quite
interesting
it says somatostatin analog now let me
explain what that means an analog is
something that mimics something and
somatostatin is a hormone that lowers or
inhibits growth hormone
insulin
and glucagon but the black seed oil
was the only
natural somatostatin analog that i could
find
out of a database of thousands and
thousands of natural remedies so this
right here will create an anti-cancer
effect because it blocks certain
pathways
that allow the cancer to
get its material its raw material to
grow and then we get to number eight
anti-convulsant so if someone has a
seizure
this could help them all right number
nine neural protection so if there's
um a lot of free radical damage or
oxidation going on the brain
black seed can help counter that so it's
a powerful anti-oxidant
all right number 10 it can protect
against kidney disease like a kidney
problem from having diabetes or a kidney
problem that is developed from a person
taking
tylenol
antibiotics certain steroids being
exposed to lead mercury
cadmium aluminum
and even morphine so black seed oil is
very very protective on the kidney if
someone
is in a situation where they have to
take certain medications that have a lot
of side effects it's also diuretic it
can also help to inhibit dermatitis
which is a skin problem it can help
support the immune system by increasing
phagocytosis which are the cells that
gobble up and clean up infection and
it's anti-gas so in summary black seed
pretty much handles about every single
problem
that you may experience thanks for
watching
hey before you go real quick i have a
course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it and here's why
here's you
here is your
environment everyone is focused on this
over here avoiding your environment but
what about here what about strengthening
your immune system
that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own
immune system i put a link down in the
description right down below
check it out and get signed up today